ma tu lo sai che ogni caso di volta che
registra uno del genere i miei capelli
finiscono così a causa del cazzo di
infatti che mi prendo i tuoi cliccato su
sto video nella speranza di vedervi
prendere un attacco di cuore grazie sei
molto questa persona veramente gentile
grazie non volevo neanche dirtelo ma
grazie porca trainava adesso svelando
lega io vi lascio al video e vado a
procurarmi un cazzo di pechino 30 e io
no io non voglio problemi ok ok gesù
grandissimo ragazzi per è un hotel a
cinque stelle è la suite questa perfetta
allora servizio in camera forza sta
arrivando nessuno perfetto a me non
importa ragazza voi ragazzi non c'è il
servizio in camera non si può dormire
alleati e caso serve sto posto fatemi
che cosa avete messo a fare a distrarmi
cioè non ho capito io torni indietro una
volta c'era c'era un sentiero tanto
tempo fa comunque sembra di essere il
cappuccetto rosso non è che devo andare
a trovare la nonnina non lo so ho
trovato un sentiero non chiedetemi dono
e piazza porta ma dove siamo
e come se non bastasse tratto c'è anche
un bivio se fantastica allora io vado
qui sotto perché mi piace di più è poi
poi penso ad andare di ciò che seguendo
una casa sto vedendo ma mi pare che ci
sia una casa la sopra non vorrei
sbagliarmi comunque andiamo prima di qua
ci sono queste costruzioni che mi
rassicurano tantissimo comunque io
ancora non sto capendo chi cazzo era
quel team non ho capito chi era quel
tizio chi cazzo è quella roba di brega
questa è la risposta no seriamente c'è
una casa di come mai c'è una casa nel
mezzo del nulla
io vado a cerci un'altra strada perfetta
la sentite io entro qui dentro
se mi fate incazzare esco subito ok ci
siamo intesi perfetto
perché stai cambi perché all'improvviso
si è messo a camminare
non ho capito perchè non potevi correre
come prima era meno era meno in tensione
la cosa per primi hanno mosso mamma tu
che mi porti lo zaino per andare a
scuola
mamma mamma io non so chi cazzo era quel
tizio ma non era la mamma di sicuro o un
ragazzina based trovato c'è veramente
una casa casino dice o per scalzare c'è
veramente una casa rega chi cazzo
avviterebbe in un posto così fantastico
sembra non lo so questo resort hawaii
l'avevo visto l'altro giorno su internet
a berlino i porti non so chi cazzo
vivrebbe mai qui perché ci sono i libri
di skyrim
non lo so c'è frigo c'è anche l'anno non
c'è la nutella inutile che la cia con la
modella in una foresta dove quando è
stata costruita sta casa manco c'era la
nutella cos'è sta roba un'altra pietra
ho preso un altra con oddo e di pietra
non capita che servono ma ne ho due
neanche l'attaccapanni c'è di tutto non
ho la giacca però prendo freddo
salve ventaglio e questo sta tornando il
pollo si aspetta non toccare il forno
mica come solo fa
di quella [ __ ] sta di casa la prossima
volta cucini to ragazzi ve lo chiedo per
favore qualcuno mi sa spiegare chi cazzo
è sto tizio che io io non ci posso più
di papasso di qua perché [ __ ] e
non posso passare il a mi chiami piglia
tosta e scuola la finestra non lo so
dunque non ragazzi non posso torino ci
posso fare se la posso fare
non va va va al cuore come cazzo è
possibile d'arma togliti dai [ __ ]
non è possibile riga ma che sommando
megawatt e vi si può dare un apporto al
massimo non la casa aiuto
ma cos'hanno si può uscire non si può
uscire o anche a [ __ ] e questa è una
sensazione di poter chiudere tutto
rientrato stai buono
stai calmo calmo calmo sono sono sono
qui tranquillo io ho le mani in alto
non sto facendo niente è una cosa che
stanno appoggiando frega
pregate che sa fare ha detto no io non
volevo neanche venirci sto posto di
merda io volevo scegliere le vacanze
alle hawaii
perché siamo venuti qui allora ragazzi
adesso che abbiamo la nostra bellissima
pietra possiamo vantarci né con gli
amici
le abbiamo e speriamo ci nei [ __ ]
come si deve andiamo nell'altra strada
siccome ragazzi ci rimane soltanto una
strada poi non ho più niente perché ho
già visto tutto tranne questo non
l'avevo visto ci manca praticamente una
strada sola che sarebbe questa quindi
spero me ma allora sei bastardo che
milan c ad hoc cos'è ragazzi cè un se
c'è un secchio posseduto
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo neanche che
ha scalato cestino fantastico la mamma
non ha mai detto che non si gira con i
secchielli stronzo magari stava giocando
con la paletta e il secchiello non lo so
ragazzi porca [ __ ] via cos'è quella
roba lì
bella casa di pri non era a casa di
prima che dove cazzo sia forse è una è
un è un villaggio ma c'è qualcuno qui
dentro
i ragazzi sono fa vj sono vengo in pace
non come quel tizio che rompe i [ __ ]
la vedo già un oggetto che carroccio un
piatto dall'ara ragazzi ci manca un
oggetto che mi ha vomitato addosso
qualcuno lo so perché vedo verde
non lo so che non posso andarci perché
mi manca di raccogliere ancora qualche
oggetto non so quale oggetto
spero di trovarlo nelle vicinanze perché
di tornare indietro non ne ho voglia
grazie mille che c'è un cazzo di
primario cioè io qui sto volentieri
basta che non passi il treno è abitata
nello stridente quando è una giornata di
merda non c'è verso allora ragazzi
facciamo finta di niente ci è crollato
un ponte
io lo so stato voi non avete visto
niente se qualcuno chiede ma dove il
caso siamo che spuntano case a minchia
era quella di prima a non è cosa di
questa rossa effettivamente perché ci
sono terremoti ovunque va bene un
importo non interessa entriamo qui da
non vorrei ritrovarmi con il deficiente
anche qui dentro comunque l'allora
l'entrata identica caso jean che già non
hai capito un cazzo se inizi così non
hai capito niente è una cosa accadrà
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi cieca verso screen volevo andare
avanti a capire che cazzo una pietra chi
è che ha stoppato il disco comunque ho
trovato un'altra pietra l'utilità listi
oggetti mi lascia perplesso st porta non
era aperta prima grazie scritto già
guarda cosa guarda fuori
leviamoci dai fottuti co adesso che
oltre pietre ragazzi potrò mai passare
di qua non mi vomitato addosso di nuovo
non mi vomitato addosso di nuovo
perfetto allora non passiamo iniqua di
seguire i binari del treno ci proverò di
sicuro qualcosa di bello sono convinto
come i ragazzi non c'era è una galera
no non è una galleria una galleria non
si capisce un cazzo è una ragazzi io non
cio non c'entrano miley dentro sappiate
lo ammetto io c'era veramente e cerca un
oggetto dentro perfetto ragazzi abbiamo
trovato un oggetto voi sapete che non
finiva bene vero qualche dove c'è il
rosso è un problema effettivamente
perché succede sempre qualcosa semi
chiusi dentro
senta io so che lei è seduto comodo per
io c'ero io il posto vicino a finestrino
finiti delle toglie vabbè io la lascio
lì perché sa molto comodo vedo come
ultima cosa però si faccia un bagno per
cortesia che non è che c'è qua siamo in
un luogo pubblico non può fare come
cazzo vuole io vado non vado da nessuna
cazzo di parte ha spinto qualcuno
ragazzi già spinto qualcuno non è
possibile mosso il treno prima di
tornare indietro volevo dare un'occhiata
qua dentro visto che promette molto bene
sì sto male effettivamente sto molto
male ho dei problemi quindi io entro gli
altri posti senza motivo la donna che
buio perché si vede un cazzo ragazzi si
comincia il binario che sta bussando mi
conviene andare avanti e cani però calmi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e uno spavento condizionato perché lo
sapevo da qualche parte si è aperto un
passaggio si ok ci aperto vuol dire sia
perche non devo tornare lì dentro grazie
a dio
ok nessuno mi ha vomitato in testa e
questo è un buon segno quindi possiamo
andare avanti la testa dopo anni ho
trovato la cazzo di testa abbiamo sette
ragazzi adesso lo rivendiamo su ebay
tutto completo che cazzo succede
sì ma per te poi se uno sconto non lo so
se lo faccio sono ancora indeciso vabbè
tanto ciò anche le pietre quelle sono
maggio
tu credi che io passi di libri led che
io ci passi vivere sta minkia amico a
perfetto sapevo lo sapevo lo sa per non
si scala [ __ ]
lo sapevo si si lo sai grandissimo non
ho trovato il modo per aggirare quello
stronzo sono convinto che ha dato una
botta alla finestra [ __ ] su ca su
una cosa sono passati di qua ragazzi non
so come dove il cazzo devo andare di
preciso è stato un piacere io levo le
tende
grazie mille nell'ospitalità fantastici
cosa la strada attraverso il ponte sia
aperta quale ponte di che cazzo di
fronte sta parlando legale non ho mai
visto un ponte non lo so devo cercarlo
ragazzi cerchiamo un ponte
c'è una non si può neanche aggiustare i
capelli il bacio che mi arriva un tizio
nudo che corre così a caso va bene io
l'ho dimenticato che ce la sto bivio
perfetto allora ci siamo dovrebbe essere
qua ok il check point c'è perfetto
ragazzi ci dovremmo essere aica gato
questo il ponte bellissimo complimento i
fantasmi poi di questi sono i ponti che
vi danno una sicurezza che non ne avete
idea comunque siccome è passato quel
tizio di prima tanto lo so che succede
qualcosa lo so che ho scritti in testa
la con iniziato sto gioco che deve
subito sapevo nulla tutto crolla tutto
crolla tutto minchia che culo macro alla
motorola ma crolla no ma anche nato un
cazzo perfetto allora che il caso niente
ma per otello davvero sono il caso
divertente sono il cazzo di me gente è
una cosa allora siete basta non possono
anche ritornare indietro siamo
dall'altra parte del ponte ragazzi non
chiedetemi cosa c'è di qua non ne ho la
più pallida idea
è esplosa esplosa la pioggia da un
momento all'altro così piove e non devo
raccogliere di niente già allora già da
casa che certo colore già non va bene
già non avete capito un cazzo perché non
c entro quando
ma neanche a murano ma neanche se me lo
chiedi in cinese
cioè una cosa che non farò mai inserisci
ossa ragazzi in vendita su ebay adesso
vi faccio una foto lo metto su ebay è
una corsa fantastica e bellissimo
complimenti perfetta amico mi ha
allenato lasciato lo scheletro li
seguendolo a vedere prima guardi e poi
compri ok non fare non fare allora io io
entro pro tu stai calmo e malmo al motto
non piove non piano che tetto di imèr la
cia sta a casa che piove dentro comunque
non importa l'importante che cos'è sto
coso ok io io lo prendo è lo prendo
coprendo ok oppure ho preso fuoco a
buongiorno
allora sei thiolas uno scheletro
dinamico
lo vado a vedere faccia cazzo che è
uguale poi sei interessato nello com
ma dopo tutto il casino che ho fatto ci
mancherà ci mancava solo questo cos'è
sta roba
una nota tutto è pronto per il rituale
stasera sveglieremo gli spiriti e veloci
dovranno la vita eterna non possiamo
aspettare
mi dispiace per la mia piccola pillola
sarà ma io l'ho cresciuta per compiere
questo rituale il suo sacrificio non
sarà mai invano e sono sicuro che
nell'aldilà starà meglio mischia kercher
che lettera di merda è questa ragazzi
usciamo allora vediamo di parlarci
chiaro rituale si fa ma prima mi colpì
lo scheletrone che ha fatto tutto sto
casino per niente ci son cazzi tuoi
cioè allora adesso adesso vediamo dove
sei dove sei diventato quel tizio
inserisci pietre una serie le tute
madonna devo farmi tutto il giro che
palle sì sono pigro ragazzi sono pigro
devo farmi questo casino ragazzi ci
siamo le pietre vale il 25 per cento in
più però adesso vorrei che la pietra
sono gratis mi sono fatto alcuno anche
per prendere quella adesso devo provare
qualche tasto un'altra pietra perché ce
l'ho messa a braga c'era quella zona
quella massa è perfetto adesso che ci
sono tutte c'è un problema
no adesso ho messo tutto come sta
rompete i [ __ ] non lo so
il mondo dopo gente di ogni genere
la coppia
è una cosa sa cosa sta succedendo e la
motivo e la vita eterna e per me ragazzi
po troppi per in eterno
e bellissimo questo momento lo voglio
condividere con tutti poi è una cosa no
no effettivamente se n'è andato tutto a
[ __ ] o magari la jackie dama di
coppia è finita è finita ragazzi abbiamo
visto lega abbiamo vinto lo riconosco
dalla musica perché se no non avrei mai
detto
ok la musica è finita quindi ce
l'abbiamo nuovamente nel culo comunque
sembra che questo sia per crollare deve
uscire di qua o certo non ha senso
stretto come mai dovrebbe crollare
[ __ ] si vabbè anche gli altri
anche il perfetto ci mancava solo questo
processo sta andando
non lo so neanch'io ma per chi è
crollato il cammino per casinò ca zzo
ragazzi
una valigia una barca [ __ ] corrive
l'ho mai dai cazzo dai sei una barca di
merda d'uscita ragazzi non lo so se si
può si può essere più lenti comic
azzeccato viviamo in cui ci si poteva
morire dal ridere se cade voli vi giuro
ce l'ho fatta ho preso la barca non ci
posso credere
e fini come il titanic alla fine
annegarono di 20 ragazzi poche parole
c'è scritto che il dovuto metri ha
beccato uno scoglio è caduto ed è morto
affogato perfetto abbiamo finito rialzi
è stato è stata un'esperienza fantastica
ciò che le sfiorò probabilmente di un
buon umore che non avete idea caso
veramente non so parole e ricordatevi
che comunque c'è ancora lo scheletro di
meta problemi vedi che posso concludere
questo è il video è piaciuto come al
solito sotto un commento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook che come noi i
video trovata nella descrizione
senegalesi vi iscrivete riusciti
vediamolo proseguito bella ragazzi